FOR YEARS.
AN EXCITING MOMENT.
THEY LANDED IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
NIGHT AND THE PRESIDENT WILL
GREET THEM.
MORE "THE STORY" TOMORROW.
>> Tucker: A FOX NEWS ALERT, A
REMARKABLE SCENE IN ASIA TODAY.
WE WERE LOOKING AT LIFE PICTURES
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAGE
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAG,
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAGA
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAGK
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAG,
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAGW
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAGE
OF ANCHORAGE           ANCHORAGT
THREE U.S. CITIZENS DETAINED BY
THE NORTH KOREAN GOVERNMENT ARE
FLYING OUT.
THEY ARE ON THEIR WAY BACK FROM
NORTH KOREA.
THEY WERE RELEASED BY THE REGIME
I HAVE A SUMMIT MEETING.
THE PRISONERS WERE ACCOMPANIED
BY SECRETARY OF STATE MIKE
POMPEO.
THEY WILL BE LANDING RIGHT
OUTSIDE WASHINGTON, D.C.,
OVERNIGHT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE WILL MEET
THEM THERE.
A FEW MINUTES AGO THEY MADE IT
BACK AS YOU ARE SEEING NOW TO
AMERICAN SOIL.
THAT'S THE SECOND PLANE TAKING
OFF.
ED HENRY HAS DETAILS ON WHAT
WE'RE WATCHING.
>> A MAJOR COUP FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP AS MIKE POMPEO
IS COMING HOME FROM A SECOND
SECRET TRIP TO NORTH KOREA WITH
A MAJOR FOREIGN POLICY VICTORY.
A DRAMATIC DAY IN DIPLOMACY.
THESE IMAGES THAT YOU MENTION,